a prison Warden who supposedly resigned
is still getting a paycheck the eight
news now investigators continue to
uncover problems inside Nevada prisons
Vanessa Murphy has this story you're
seeing here first
a spokesperson told us a prison Warden
resigned months ago then we obtained
timesheets and the department changed
its story and this guy gets to resign
and still collect a six-figure salary
William Hutchings was the warden at
Southern desert Correctional Center
while a riot took place there in
December the department tried to
downplay it in April the 8 news now
investigators uncovered how bad it was
two months later a Nevada prison
spokesperson said Hutchings resigned for
personal reasons his final date of
employment July 15th his salary
according to the department nearly 128
thousand dollars then recently these
timesheets were obtained by the
investigators showing 40-hour work weeks
for Hutchings from July to mid-september
approved by the now acting director the
department refused to confirm whether
Hutchins is still getting paid then on
Monday we received this reply Hutchings
will be employed until November 11th the
8 news now investigators also reached
out to the governor's office a
spokesperson responded the governor's
office cannot comment because
information regarding specific Personnel
issues are confidential the governor's
office is working close with the interim
director at endoc to address ongoing
issues for the benefit of staff and in
the interest of public safety director
Charles Daniels stepped down on Friday
at the request of the governor after The
Escape of a convicted murderer from the
same prison Southern desert Correctional
Center and after the 8 news now
investigators have exposed numerous
failures and concerns at the department
Paul lundquitz heads a union
representing correctional officers he
says he believes the Department's
actions surrounding the resignation of
Hutchings and these timesheets should be
investigated what was said behind closed
doors that that would allow something
like this to happen and what is the
department thinking and just
nonchalantly saying oh he's still
employed until this date you know how
how badly does that reflect on their the
leadership of our department and we
obtained an internal Memo from the
acting director of Nevada prisons he
acknowledged the uncertainty change in
senior leadership can cause and he said
staff will continue to focus on the
basics by exhibiting what right looks
like Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now
thank you Vanessa after the eight news
now investigators published this story
on 8newsnow.com a short while ago a
Nevada prison spokesperson sent an email
stating they have received clarification
and Hutchings is on paid administrative
leave